hot breath so when you're pre-show
a lot of comics are doing a set list
what are what are you doing
to like with your pre-show ritual
i have and then i'll show you my mind
map oh yeah let's get into the mind map
for a second all right
no no but but my so wanna go um you can
go to the mind map real quick i'll pull
it up full screen too so people can see
well let me i'm even trying to see what
uh
so what i do okay i'll go back to that
so what i do is i always have
with with my stand up and all my shows
i've always had themes so it's easy for
me to construct an
hour so i used to years ago have a bit
about
me and my family are going on vacation
and we're pulling out of the driveway
and there's all that stuff
and then for an hour i would keep going
back to so we're in the car and we go
and then we stop at this place
and then all these weird decides and
then we're blah
and then we pulled in and it just locked
everything together
through the hole so it's easy for me to
bounce around and
i've kind of only had three jokes my
entire life since i was
doing comedy i literally i have i have
i'm getting older uh remember when
or reminiscing and relationship
okay those are the three those are the
kind of the three things that i'm
kind of with uh you know sprinkle i
always call it just
like literally seasoning right so those
are the random bits
and then i i would have hours of
material
on on both on on all those three things
that i said
and just with my watch every 15 minutes
i i would switch it up
so and then some shows i was going to
start with relationship stuff
and i do relationship for 15 minutes and
then i look at my thing
so 27 i'm getting older i'm almost 30
and then all this stuff that comes with
that and then him over this toy and then
i would just use my clock just out of
you know even if i'm
crushing it with relationship stuff i'd
be like it's time to move on
and i would just use that so every show
was different because
i never started with joke one and then
it would joke 10.
i would just play the chords you know
differently so it felt
more organic i think yeah i've heard
chris rock say the same thing where he
really only talks about
three things and he breaks his show up
into thirds
that's it i mean it can be that for me
i'm just inherently a little bit lazy a
writer i
i can't be all over the place because
then my brain i have to have everything
connecting
i have to have a reason why i just
brought this up and you know
i i'm just not i just hate going so what
what do you guys want to talk like i'm
not that there's a reason there's a flow
that that happens and i even sometimes
do
shady where in the beginning of the
show um
i'll go just like somebody giving a
speech
i'll go hey i got i got three things i'm
excited i'm gonna tell you guys about
one i'm gonna talk about uh my mom blah
blah blah two
ever have this happen in a relationship
and then i would just
then i would just start talking right
and
so i would do my whole show and then at
the end of the show like maybe about
five ten minutes before
i got off stage i would look at the
crowd and go
did i tell you guys the third thing and
everybody would go no like that whole
time
they were waiting for me to say what
number three was
but i only because i purposely left out
three and that's called an open loop
which i'm a crazy fan of okay when you
tell somebody you're gonna give them
something
and then you don't and then at the end
you give it to them
and then they feel oh i feel complete
that's exactly what we wanted
interesting so just the fun it's just a
fun thing to do during
yeah at least for me during the show